i'm announcing today for one year a new
business rates discount for businesses
in the retail hospitality and leisure
sectors
pubs music venues cinemas restaurants
hotels theaters and gyms any eligible
business can claim a discount on their
bills of 50 percent up to a maximum of a
hundred and ten thousand pounds
that is a business tax cut worth almost
1.7 billion pounds
together with small business rate relief
this means that over 90 percent of all
retail hospitality and leisure
businesses will see a discount of at
least 50 percent
apart from the covid reliefs
this is the biggest single year
tax cut to business rates in over 30
years
madam deputy speaker taken together
today's budget cuts business rates by 7
billion pounds